un debate lleno de acusaciones cruzadas
Reproches y salidas de la atril así fue
el primer enfrentamiento entre el
presidente brasileño Jair bolsonaro y el
candidato izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva de Cara a la segunda vuelta de
los comicios pocas horas antes del
encuentro hubo dudas sobre su
celebración tras la polémica que
envolvió al presidente por sus
comentarios sobre la apariencia física
de menores venezolanas un tema que
denunció la candidatura del izquierdista
por presunta pedofilia y que la justicia
falló a favor de bolsonaro quien se lo
recordó a su contrincante durante una de
sus intervenciones
la sentencia dice que la demanda de la
presidenta del partido de los
trabajadores el 15 de octubre se
descuelga de la realidad
y tal contexto de evidencia la
divulgación de hecho sabiamente falsos
el mandatario en un tono menos
beligerante que de costumbre destacó su
gestión económica y le recordó a Lula
sus presuntos vínculos con la corrupción
por su parte el progresista afeo a
bolsonaro su desconexión de la realidad
con las capas más empobrecidas de la
sociedad y criticó especialmente el
manejo de la pandemia
eres el rey de las fake news y de la
estupidez de mentirle a la sociedad
brasileña y tu mentiste sobre la vacuna
todo el tiempo y le quitaste importancia
a la vacuna y Brasil tiene ahora el
título del país que tuvo más muertes por
covid es lamentable a dos semanas del
balotaje donde 156 millones de
brasileños están llamados a las urnas el
polarizado clima electoral continúa su
imparable Ascenso